hello good afternoon everyone
welcome to being NDC
um I've hope you had a great time so far
and it's the second day and thank you
for coming and joining me for the talk
my name is Theresa Wu I work as a
software engineer for JP Morgan and in
addition I'm also a public speaker I'm a
Google expert for the front end
cross-platform framework called flutter
which just starts as its language and I
myself I'm a bigger fan of using
front-end cross-platform front-end
technology to build applications
and
my talk today will be many folks on uh
Franklin technology and I'm going to
give a deep dive of how we build the
Chase application and its architecture
so before we start just to have like a
big understanding of my audience today
how many of you here are front-end
engineers
awesome okay more than half at least
from what I can see and
have you ever heard or used the Chase
app
it's a mobile application
okay great so yeah so
um the Chase mobile application was
first launched in the US it was one of
the biggest
banking banking for in the US in the US
and about two years ago we launched the
same application in the UK but it's
digital only that means we run no Branch
zero branch in the UK it's everything
digital so building is front-end
projects is really interesting and I
will talk to you about how we create out
the architecture to enable us to scale
so if you imagine this is a big team a
massive project and
we started from building it with really
fun Innovations and towards end we do
have our difficulties and we will I will
talk you through how we create my
profundance to um enhance we can
continue our journey and this
application can then scam so let's begin
right uh before we go into very Tech
detail of the project itself I'm going
to just quickly do some
talk about some Theory right in case you
never heard of micro front end but I'm
sure you heard the terms of
microservices so micro frontant is very
similar and in terms of the theory it's
very similar to microservices
it's basically divide your project from
monoliths to something smaller like
something you can easily manage both and
you can chunk into smaller pieces in the
front in the project and it's probably
harder in the front in the project
especially for when it comes to mobile
because when we build a project for
mobile for example in end of the day we
still have to release it as a monolith
project but there are lots of ways we
can actually enhance this journey
so micro frontant what it means is um
we actually slice the whole project into
a modules or packages I'm sure if you
are front-end Engineers your project is
for today might not be a monolith
project anymore you might have different
modules different packages in a project
this is how we start with our Chase
application as well but in the end we do
find other difficulties like coupled
couple
um dependencies and we think about our
versioning Solutions but we shall talk
about those a bit more later on
so micro Fountain is slice the project
into smaller packages
and they can so each of the modules is
interchangeable like you can use them as
a Lego like a package like a library
and this allows us to decouple release
from development
that means by end of this project we
want to enable that we can release on
demand
and we can also roll back versions
as well
so why do we need to build our project
in a micro function style right so first
it it enable us to have the
cross-function team to give end-to-end
responsibility for a feature
and the team have decisions of when to
release what feature
and they also have their own decision
for the tech stack of their packages and
their modules and in this way it's more
effective because you have smaller code
base to work with and it will be more
efficient because
it will be easier to upgrade
and to maintain and be optimized for
feature development
I've been told I need to click it in a
certain angle
right a little bit introduction of the
chase UK app so Chase look up is
actually different from chase us up even
though we are on the chase family the
chase UK app is actually pure digital we
have no branch and it was a Greenfield
project which was quite amazing because
for example company like um
a big Investment Bank to start a project
totally from scratch using the latest
technology was kind of a deal so the
chase UK app is um is a Greenfield
project and we build them from scratch
it was launched in UK in 2021.
and it was hit like a very successful it
was it went to almost like a 1 million
um downloading and have 1 million
customers just within a year and the
number is still going and we I think we
hit number one downloading in both of
the App Store
and it was built with relative so it's a
cross-platform
so how is a project look like from like
a very high level overview
so we the most of the features like for
example I think over
um 80 of the features in the project is
built with real native that means we
have a typescript underneath right and
for most of the features like onboarding
uh payment inside account cards those
features and some of the shared packages
are built with relative and this is a
part we actually have worked on since
last year to re-architecture ways we
applied micro-fronted ways
and on top of the real native framework
we have the native framework and
sometimes we use a bridge to to connect
native and Via native and those Android
and iOS sitting on top we have our
native application code for since we
couldn't really do much with relative
first is because we are the bank we are
being monitored and there are lots of
regulations and it's for many reasons
like for security and for um
like for example the networking logins
right and authentications are done in
Native
and we use the modular structure and we
have feature package and share package
right so this is like a from a project
architecture from a high-level view of
our application
great so after we've been following this
architecture for over like a year
building a project having a feature ink
and starting to make releases
everything is fine at the point we have
a team from bike and engineer Cloud QA
front-end team over like uh people full
of like a floor a certain number
everyone's happy until the point we
found okay where it is done challenges
and
we do have a modular approach project
and we have a mono reports so that means
all our front-end code underneath one
repo
and we do have multiple packages right
but underneath of those modules we have
Circle dependencies so what happens like
one day we happily decoding our
functions and what Engineers decided to
draw this um
big graft tree of our project this is
not a picture of our project but very
close right we end up having this
diagram showing in front of us like work
okay hold on this is not something we
want to see
so having dependence is actually fine
which I will explain why later but
either is all your
dependencies pointing to One Direction
either up or down depends on how your
project is depending on each other but
having those arrows up
pointing both directions that means your
project is um definitely have the
symptoms of circle dependencies and
having stock dependencies would
definitely break your um your way yeah
your journey to have your project in the
microphone in the style so we did a lot
of work here to break it and that would
be explained as well
and having those circular dependencies
means even though our project is modular
approach everything's splits but what
happens in the end is if one thing or
one feature had Arrow this Arrow will
still impact the whole project because
this error in this module will impact
another module
and in this way we sing Delight in our
release process and we have then delayed
our release training as well
so we decided to
um Deep dive in this problem and find a
way to solve it
so here is our Solutions and in this
presentation I'm going to work you
through those steps a bit more in detail
one by one so we started with skip
analyze of the project and did some POC
and the lots of Workshop to understand
what is actual problem
believe me to see that last point of
having circuit dependency and
understand what we need to solve it took
us actually a few of good Workshop to
come to that conclusion
so we analyze the project and the
architecture of it
and we did a lot of Spike and there was
like the tools that I can use
so and we I just spent a lot of time and
effort to break psychodependencies
and
in the end so everything we do is to
enable every engineer to build the
project in a more efficient and more
effective way but this all contribute to
the integral that we can release in a in
a very modern format release easily
and in the end grab everything we do we
we designed our release process
so first of all the architecture
so we are saying we our project has um
relative under this uh most of them is a
real native and on top it has Android
and iOS native code but if we take a
closer look of the actual module
architecture
we actually follow the principle of a
feature driven development which is a
bit different from DDD but similar ish
so we actually our Micro frontant Design
is quite
um
similar actually almost the same it's a
mirror of our backing service so we do
actually recreate or regenerate another
type of layer or architecture away from
our backend service we actually try to
mirroring it to make sure both teams can
speak the same language and we can
understand each other and this is also
how we structure the team as well
so if on the bike inside we have
services like onboarding account then we
have the mirroring modules in the front
end
so we have more than those modules but
it's like a big closer look of that what
the project looks like so we have some
feature modules which are on the top of
the tree which is like a node
those are like the service like
onboarding account service cards
and in the center you see like lots of
smaller pieces those others shared
package
and they are for example Authentication
to that system
iot future Vlog and a bit more and those
shared packages are getting shared among
those modules and you can create a rules
of what it means for your project to be
shared or to be an independent node
so so far so good right we are happy
with this structure and it's probably
common for most of the front-end
projects but we do find the one issue
here is navigation
so navigation in a front-end project at
this point for us isn't done in a very
clean way why because if you think about
navigation it actually goes everywhere
so one solution is you have navigation
your routing system at the enter point
when you go to the application item main
so we'll enter the app you grab the
routing system you grab this logic and
you apply it everywhere so that means
every time you want to use navigation
you grab it from the root
that means all your modules will have
this dependency of the root package
which is probably the main application
this look might look like a clean way
but every time we update the route
think about the packages might be
impacted with
so it might look cool clean but it
doesn't help us with dependencies
so another solution is that we can
actually group navigation and symbolize
what we've done in the main but we put
in a share module so it actually went
down a bit lower to the closer to the
domain level but it's the problem hasn't
been solved as well that means if I have
navigation as a package as a module
every time when someone at or rename
delete
or modify a routine system like how we
navigate from screen a to string to
screen B
this change will again impact everyone
else who has dependency to it
so is a better way to solve this
navigation there probably are and
there'll probably be someone who is
smarter like serving this issue or maybe
put this system on a cloud so you can
you can grab it when you need it right
so what we've done is we have a
combination of of things
so if we want to navigate externally
from one module to a different module
for example if you want to jump from
payment
to um to my profile this external
connection was was stored in navigation
package in a share package so this is
called share package or shared
navigation
but anything you do locally within this
your own package so everything that you
navigate within your onboarding service
or payment service this navigation is
actually stored and hold within this
feature module itself
so some of the code follow this way the
project is cleaner but the downside of
it is we do see more code duplication
which is fine
so it's okay to have your code
duplicated for the reason of solving
Circle dependencies depends on how much
you have to copy your code
so we actually decided this is
architecture wouldn't follow we have our
first solution of navigation
and
to to read write to this navigation
system took us some time as well but
after we applied it around the graph
again we do see the the map it's getting
cleaner which is great
so another thing we did a very big
um
discussion as well in in a project
arctics level is the version
so imagine that you have a big project
with multiple packages within it how do
you version each package how do you
version each module if you if we didn't
come up with a very smart solution
later on when we actually release those
modules we might hit a pen point
so we decide not again not to be super
creative but to be safe so we use a
server system which means
you have the major
uh Manner and the patch so each of the
breaking points release will become a
major release
and each feature update or a new feature
being added will be a manner and again
I'll talk about how we handle version
system in a very Automatic Auto in Auto
way that we don't do this manually
anymore
and each patch will be each small change
that anyone can use will be a patch
so in our project we care about major
and we look we watch out for
um
manner but we ignore patch that anyone
can update patch anytime and we accept
changes from hatch automatically
I'm sorry for my bullet points it says
one it should be with number but
you guys can work this out
and we look at our
um
git strategy as well so how many of you
here
think you are using trunk a strategy
okay okay great it's actually nice to
use trunk but the thing is for myself my
own experience this is not something I
do I talk I you know for Chase don't
call to me honest but whenever I work on
your project I hear people telling me
they are using chunker base I look twice
because
having a main branch and always commit
to the main branch doesn't actually mean
you are using trunk-based development
chunk-based development is actually
means every time you commit you are
confident the code is ready to release
that means you have to do lots of
testing lots of code check before you
commit
so we were using trunk initially
but anyway we actually changed to use
git flow this is due to the mobile
application nature
that we still have to release
through the release cycle of the App
Store so having a git flow actually
works for us in a way that we have a
main branch and we actually kind of in
between right now actually sorry we are
using the
um what was the name for it there's
another strategy in between trunk and
the git flow and I can't remember
sorry so we we don't have developed
branch and the main branch so we have a
main branch but at the main branch we
actually feature out of
Branch out our feature branch and we
also have a release Branch as well
I think it's called enhanced trunk
development or something right so when
you actually look at your module
versioning you need to think about what
to get what git strategy you're using as
well so your kid strategy might have
impact on your version system
so
so right now we are using sounds in
between
and then we trade every merge as a
commit to publish and each publish will
occur a version Bank of each package and
this was done in an automatic way
and once we actually when someone commit
to their code they are they actually opt
in for their code to be published as a
module as a new version of that module
and the two artifacts
that means another team can use their
published live published module as a
library
and also we applied testing strategy to
support backwards completely
compatibility as well actually I've been
working on this for the past two three
weeks for this testing strategy so
in our micro micro front end
architecture we um almost like towards
the end we realized we do have some
Singleton package that means every time
when someone publish a new version of
those Singleton package our application
speaks lower to react to those Singleton
package because of the global instance
so wait so we worked on a system that
can detect those changes be early in
time to support backward compatibility
right so that's the project level how we
architecture projects in a modular way
thinking about navigation and the
version system as well what was the time
okay okay uh
right then we're starting to implement
Solutions largely enable us to to
decouple the project to make to bump the
version and to cash as well which is
very important
so those are a few tools we used we we
were using um
so we were using yarn before and we
switched to pmpm also we took out the
learner and we use a webpack because
there was uh because we use relative
right so for people who are familiar
with Iran native underneath the hood
Metro is the bundler but
in the beginning when we actually work
on the project Metro doesn't really
support Sim link but right now there's a
plugin you can use with Metro that does
support the same link now so webpack
support Sim link and the code splitting
naturally
and pmpm allow you to um basically if
you use um young which is great
um how it managed the dependence is a
bit different from pmpm
because we want to go with micro front
and style so we want to force each
module to be to have its own ecosystem
that means every module should have its
own
dependencies in the packages so we we
switch to use pmpm
and change set was the two hours
dimensioner BRD when we do a diversion
system to pump version to
um to pack each version like for example
manner or major
and it also if I pump the version of
this module which was used in a
different package I don't want to
manually check if this was impacted
right so having this tool called change
set will be the one actually can manage
those um version for you
and we also use turbo Ripple which again
is so great too that you can use a turbo
report to First prevent cycle
dependencies for you and it does the
caching as well
right so after the implementation
of those tools we actually
so actually this was something we've
done in parallel because you have to
solve your circle dependency in order to
use the full power of pmpm and the Turbo
so basically if your project has circuit
dependency
you won't be able to use turbo report at
all
and once you have turbo reporting
anyone who submits a pull request that
creates a circle dependency turbo will
actually break so which was actually
very smart
so we actually did a circle dependence
in parallel with incoming those tools
so in your project right we definitely
definitely should avoid having cell
codependency and we should use package
management as well
and sometimes we actually can use we so
when we start learning programming right
probably the first thing we heard from
school is um is not do not repeat
yourself but for the purpose of having
your projects in the microfronting style
sometimes you do have to duplicate your
code
to reduce circuit dependency
and also to to improve efficiency as
well
and
right so
maybe we can talk about a bit more here
of how we break dependencies which is a
lot of work again
so imagine you have some share modules
right those can be shared payments
should onboarding share accounts that is
has the common code you need to apply to
support your node your top left your top
level node modules
but having them changed means you will
have to change your top level package as
well
so in this way
if you want to avoid half circle
dependence that means for example your
module a have dependency of module B
and the module B have dependence of
module C the inner way ANS is also
connected so those three have Circle
dependency right so what we can do is um
we can take the work of the module for
example C we can break a stay into two
modules
this could be one one of the way to
solve your circle dependency that means
that B can depending on C and A can
depend on C independently so c will be
split into two
or as what I'm saying is we actually
delete module C if it says actually
press more so instead of having merge as
module C we have CS code duplicated in
module a and module B
so depends on the functions and uh your
code design and so you have to decide
this with your team see what is the best
option for you
and we can split the module
or even remove them by having them
duplicate each module or we can even
merge a module so Circle dependency
happens when so for example in our
project we have over 70 packages and we
actually used all three functions so we
also merged some module as well from
three to one
so this is how we solved our Circle
dependency
right and as well I'm saying is right so
the first part of this presentation is
about how we design the project
how we build it and how we solve the
versioning and how we actually make sure
that we can build in a microphone in the
style
but this allows each team to work more
independently happily but in end what we
want to achieve is to release the module
in a micro frontal style because what's
the big advantage that we have to split
the module if we can release them so
the other part of this talk will focus
now on the pipeline design and release
management
right
so
if you worked in a front-end project or
more specifically mobile application
you probably experience this the Pang of
release so for us we have
we run Sprint and every two weeks we cut
the release branch and this build we're
going to having been tested end-to-end
manual accessibility
and once back are detected the
application will be put on the hold
before we can release it to production
and one team will have to solve this
issue that means this team went well
this team solving the issue every other
team will have to be on hold so
basically we couldn't release the
project and everything is being kind of
delayed so one bug will delay the
delivery of the project
across the entire department
so the goal of our new release process
is we want to enable in a way that each
module can be deployed independently
and we can release on demand without
restrictions or dependencies
and we want to avoid having breaking
changes in production
and we want to separate our city
from so if without having micro function
way of a release we'll have integration
Pipeline and do have this deployment
Pipeline and with this new approach
we have a secondary pipeline between
which allows us to publish a module
under and version it so this is our
publish and release pipeline so we have
a third pipeline now to supporting it
so again so the one not used in the pink
area is the project design the build
within our development software
engineering team we look after the
project in the front and the way the
module the model dependency the version
system but having this project to be
released in a microphone style this was
actually involved of the effort of many
other team as well
so when we did our approach we actually
did lots of workshop with other teams in
the same project right
so
we in a in a pink Zone we will be the
engineers to build the features and we
will decide which module we want to
release
the team will have the power to decide
when to release their features right
and the the uh the engineer who are in
the core platform team
the CCT pipeline ting
will be the one to integrate to actually
write the script to deliver these
functions to deploy as well so they will
be the supporting of this operation
right and then when we talk about
release we have the release management
team as well to work with them to
discuss our new Solutions and what we
should do to have advice from them of
saying
now we change the release process a bit
so instead of grabbing a code from from
the work space like every time when you
commit to the git at the time we release
we actually cut the the project and we
grab the code from the latest last
commit which was not tested heavily
and this will be a change now is we're
going to grab the code which was tested
thoroughly
versioned and published so in the end
our release of the app will contain
modules which is bit is tested earlier
so we shift test to the left
so again that means we have to work with
testing testing and engineering team as
well
so they will decide for us like when
under what should be tested for each
module to be published
we also changed some of our testing
functions as well
so this was actually a very big project
in the end so we have contribution from
testing from the pipeline from release
and from the front-end team to put
together this microphone on the project
so
if you have a look of the release
process having a monolith project and
the release it as a big massive
application that means we can release at
the end of each Sprint
we might have a long leaf release branch
and we manually miss this release string
or having this trim being irrelevant e
regular
follow the microfronting the style we
actually couple release from development
that means we're testing B early and we
shift test to left and we might not
release Branch anymore because in end of
the day and when we release the project
we grab all the released version of each
package and each module and the bundle
them into a big application and release
it
so
a few other design of the pipeline I
followed the strategy from Google but
this is what they also recommend as well
so Street pipeline so first is
integration the recommended running time
for integration that means this pipeline
will be triggered when someone creates a
pull request
the recommended time to run this
pipeline is around 10 minutes which is
bit
difficult for fronting the project
because of the testing
and this should be quite fast for faster
feedback and to to show the fillers and
tests fail as well
so once you run your integration
Pipeline and everything is successful
the engineer should be able to merge
their pull request to the main branch
and delivery is what we also internally
we call this published pipeline we run
this pipeline to publish our module to
version it and to
put this um package in artifacts for
other team to consume as a library
so this one should be quite close to
your releasable code
to production ready so this published
the wrong bit longer and have a bit more
tests that you run underneath this
pipeline for example like this again
depends on your team
at PR level you want to run full tests
for unit tests and maybe some of the
snapshots as well
I'd publish level you probably want to
including more of like for the detox
tests a bit of a little bit end-to-end
not a full set of end-to-end and having
also a number of the thresholds of how
how many tests coverage you want to hive
as well for this pipeline we also have
this rule of code owner that means if we
are the code owner of this team then you
have to be there you have to at least do
a check or do a quick check of the code
being released
so in the end you have to wait down the
first two so in end we're actually
having a very
um smoothly easier-ish deployment
pipeline which is to grab the code
package the code and
then are deployed to the App Store
and this pipeline should be protected in
a way because
product in the way that you should have
limited access right because you have
more requirements for authentication at
this pipeline
so
so let's talk a bit closer look of the
center uh the the published pipeline
which is again
when we look at this purely it doesn't
have lots of um it's not really mystery
it's the only thing that is different
from this one to the integration or to
the actual deployment is the tests be
wrong and the decision we took to make
this pipeline to fail that means this
build isn't success isn't successful
and what we should do if this pipeline
is unsuccessful
so as usual we grab the code we perform
the check and we have some rules of what
this pipeline should be successful for
it should have
um for example 80 percent of a test
coverage it should have a full uh unit
Test passing rate
and in the end if it fell it goes back
to the the product team who is opt in to
publish their feature
and once we run the tests and we're
happy with the test result then we run
the script of the changes set to a
version this package to Bamboo version
as well and at the same time
this code commit will contain the
version bank for other modules as well
so if I have a module a I bump the
module a to version 1.3 right that means
whoever use this module a will have
their packages changed from version 1.2
to 1.3
and this is the whole process of our
publish pipeline
right
so up to now after
over the work over a year
in a team we managed to to actually get
very very close to our goal to have this
new release release process that means
when at the team level each team they
build a feature
the team decide that they opt in of when
they want to release the feature that
means they can trigger the pipeline to
publish it
right and the pipeline will be triggered
and the bump of the version build and
published to artifacts
and in artifacts the new version is
published
it can be consumed as a library
and in end of the day all these prices
will contribute and accelerate the app
release as well
so as a summary the results what we
achieve is um
we still using via native before after
the framework is the same
we were using metro and we use in Metro
as well because now Metro has support
for Sim link but in the end we also had
the metro running in parallel with
webpack
and in terms of the package we used yarn
and a learner now we use sorry that was
awesome mistake I apologize for that so
after we use them pmpm
as a replacement and we also added
changes set as to manage the version
system
so how do we be how can we success micro
front end right so this is a process
right it's not one of tasks we it took
us actually very long to design and
Implement micro frontant in our
application
and it requires a team collaboration
right it's it's we have we formed a
small team to do these tasks
independently and worked with many other
team as well to come up with that with
this solution
and yeah we designed the project
we make sure there's a zero Circle
dependency
and we started to from one module which
is a core module and then slowly moving
on to each feature module and we have
also decoupled our tests so you have
unit tests integration and end-to-end
and in the end we also have built the
pipeline to support and ship the micro
bundle as well
so thank you this is my talk
[Applause]